[Music]
welcome to another episode of i've got a
question today's question is is any
screen time safe for kids
you know that's a great question and one
that i know a lot of parents are
thinking about here's what we know the
american academy of pediatrics
recommends no screen time for children
under two
now there is a newer study called the
abcd study and there is a recommendation
for no screens for children under 18
months
however there's some other important
things that came out of this study as
well
what is consumed should be limited to no
more than a couple of hours per day for
children who are of age and it's not
just what you consume but how you
consume it the abcd study makes the
point that children should not consume
screens alone they should have an adult
to interact and help guide the child as
they view things on the screen
also remember that not all content is
created equal pediatricians are really
recommending that it be educational type
content
another interaction that falls in that
realm are the personal ones so things
like facetime and other forms of video
chat with friends and relatives do not
have the same effects on children that
entertainment based programming does
so the short answer is that less is
better and when you do choose to intake
media do it with your child and make
sure that you're choosing things that
are
educational
[Music]
i hope that that helps and feel free to
reach out to us with other media related
questions you can do so through email or
social media we have done other videos
so feel free to check them out and share
them with those to help those in your
circles that may be wondering the same
things as you
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you